- Hi, everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
And I just want to remind everyone
that as we're going through
what's clearly a very difficult
time in the world generally,
but especially in education,
that the entire team here at Khan Academy
is dedicated to making sure that teachers,
and parents, and students feel and are
as supported as possible.
But I also like to remind everyone
that we're not-for-profit,
and we can only exist because
of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you believe in a
free world class education
for anyone anywhere,
which I think is more relevant than ever,
please think about making
a donation to Khan Academy.
We were running at a deficit
even before the COVID crisis hit.
And you can imagine once the crisis hit,
our traffic has been two to three X
of what it typically is,
our registrations are
10 to 20 X of normal.
And we're trying to accelerate
a whole series of programs,
not only supporting the server load,
we've accelerated "Get Ready
for Grade Level" courses,
which make sure that
students around the world
have the ability to fill
in any gaps they need.
So that they're optimally ready
to learn at their own time,
and pace, and grade level.
We're trying to support teachers
and parents with webinars,
students with as many supports
that we can provide them.
But all of this is only
possible if we have donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making
a donation to Khan Academy.
Thank you.